Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimayo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Just for today.
Ruffians!
Today's our 44th episode!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us today!
Thank you!
It's Wednesday.
That means you've made it halfway through the week.
I don't know if I saw any Ruffians that are joining us for the first time, but... I think there's still some Ruffians that maybe aren't too sure.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Ruffians, you know what you're supposed to do here now, right?
Do you know what you're supposed to do?
I'll tell you.
Okay.
You don't have to remember, because I've got you.
Yeah.
You need to tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, like always, the Ruffians, Ruffians, Ruffians.
You might have seen Pero around, right?
Was there a Pero Sighting?
De-den!
Ruffians... Now we're getting a bit worried.
It's almost been a week now since anyone's seen Pero.
It's okay, right?
Is he really missing now?
I'm worried.
Maybe he's just gone on a really good vacation.
Hopefully.
Ruffians!
Please let us know as soon as you can if you see Pero.
I mean... Pero's pretty nasty, but... It would be bad if something happened, right Moco-chan?
It wouldn't be good.
No.
Very important, yes.
Please let us know.
Looking for Pero.
BAU BAU!
But!
Happy Endings!
Ruffians.
You watched one!
Just a few days ago, it was Marisenjo-senpai's 4th anniversary!
The concert.
The concert, right?
And she held a Showa Kaio side this year, getting a bunch of amazing hits from yesteryears.
Even more!
Even more different ones from
Why'd you say that I wasn't happy?
I was happy too!
Yes!
But, to tell the truth, we haven't been able to watch the concert yet.
Because we want to be able to take a moment to properly enjoy it, you know?
Like a yummy dessert.
You want to be able to enjoy it properly and savor it.
Yeah, you know, as you know, Ruffians, it's been a little bit busy recently.
So, but...
I'm sure Ruffians, you are aware, but I really like Japanese oldies.
So, you know, this kind of thing feels like it was made exactly for us.
Right!
Exactly!
It definitely wasn't, though.
Definitely wasn't.
It wasn't for us.
It was, though.
We can't be happier!
You know, especially because I really like my Senju-senpai, too.
We'll work hard as members of hololive so that maybe one day Senju-senpai might be interested in calling on us, too.
Maybe one day!
We'll have to work really hard!
BAU BAU!
Continuing on that, something else also happened to FUWAMOCO-chan.
Senchuu-senpai also unveiled a new original song!
Together with Gura-senpai called Shinkirou!
Of course, it's a wonderfully nostalgic song overflowing with silly pop vibes.
The music video that Senchuu-senpai had made for it is so beautiful.
We haven't had a look at it yet.
You should check it out!
Got it!
BAU BAU!
And on other news you should keep your eye on.
This is important.
Very important.
Listen up.
So, you might be surprised, but Ruffians!
There's only one week!
One week.
Not even one week.
Until Abyss Demolish Diva Nobita Mimikawa's birthday!
Yay!
Her first birthday as a member of hololive!
I'm so excited!
Yeah!
Did you know?
Well, it's okay if you didn't know because we brought you.
Now you know.
It's a week before.
You have time.
Yeah.
But actually, Ruffians, we realized we still haven't decided on a present for her.
Do you have any ideas?
Ideas, please.
Ruffians!
Ideas, please!
We can't really sing her a song because that's kind of her thing, right?
She could sing herself a song.
Maybe something that will make her smile?
Wait, did I see somebody say a whip?
What?
Ha?
Oh, soup!
Soup.
Fuwawa soup.
No?
She didn't like my gnome.
I don't know, but maybe she just doesn't know the, you know... She didn't want to know my gnome!
The good positive sides of gnomes, you know?
She didn't want to know.
The miryoku.
She didn't want to know my gnome, okay?
A big paw in the ring.
Wacking tea, that's true.
Sort of like soup.
I feel like that's more like something Shiori would give her.
It was very very close to her.
Underneath her shirt.
Moco-chan's tummy!
That's the best suggestion so far.
You should know that my tummy is mine.
It's mine.
Are you sure, Moco-chan?
Mine only, okay?
Your tummy doesn't belong to me, Chiyo.
You know we are twins, right?
So that means you can have my tummy too, Moco-chan.
No, I don't need yours.
I have mine, thank you.
Chiyo, I don't need another tummy either.
We have some really good ideas for the Ruffians.
Some.
Not all of them.
Just some.
But Ruffians, please don't let her know.
Don't let her know our plans.
It's a secret, okay?
We hope that you'll celebrate it with her and the rest of Abyss all together on November 21st.
It's a happy time.
Mark your calendars, okay?
BAU BAU!
So happy!
November 21st.
The 21st.
The 21st is Nerissa's birthday.
But that's the end of the happy news for today.
Ruffians.
I feel like it's been a bit of a while, but
It happened again.
I missed understanding.
I messed up.
Fuwawa messed up.
You know, we thought we corrected things right on the spot.
But, maybe it wasn't clear enough for you.
You know, when we were playing Fashion Dreamer on Monday, and trying to choose what kind of eyes for our muse to have, Fuwawa
She fumbled her words and she said something suspicious.
About, you know, massaging things and getting bigger.
Yeah, not good.
But, like she explained, it was about
You know, eye massage.
Face massage.
So that your eyes will look bigger, okay?
And you know, it did!
It did make Moco-chan's eyes bigger.
Yes!
But it's very dangerous.
But you know, massages can make things smaller too!
It can!
That's what we wanted to say!
You know, we've done massages for
Your legs and your face look like they're slimmer and brighter too.
There's a lot of power to massage, okay?
Right, right.
Very powerful.
So we want you to understand and know that it works both ways, okay?
Small too.
Don't misunderstand about massages.
But you know... I don't know if this is a bit selfish of me,
But... Someday... You know... I'd like to actually go get an actual massage!
You know... No.
No.
An actual massage!
Or... Even just a scalp massage!
I feel like...
You know, peak luxury is going to the hairstylist and just getting a scalp massage for 30 minutes.
I like to do that one day.
The fuzz will get even fuzzier.
I feel like my brain will end up like mush.
It might be good for a change, huh?
A mushy brain?
Mushy brain.
Not fuzzy, not fluffy.
A bit mushy.
Yeah.
Oi!
You do it to Ruffians!
That's not fair.
A scalp massage from the Ruffians?
No, no.
Professional.
Ruffians aren't professional.
You understand now, Ruffians?
Yeah, no misunderstanding.
BAU BAU!
It's good, it's good, it's good.
So, I...
My stuff happened in Fashion Dreamer.
Not a misunderstanding again.
Not a misunderstanding, but a problem.
P-problem.
So, you might have noticed, Ruffians, but during Fashion Dreamer, Fuwawa had a bit of a strange habit.
She kept on touching the monitor multiple, multiple times repeatedly.
And you know, you Ruffians, you thought it was sorta cute.
You thought it was good fun, all that.
But really, the reality is that it was not cute.
Each time, it was very terrifying.
Cuz you know, each touch, it wasn't really as much of a touch as it was a very strong push with your finger.
As if... Almost trying to push right through the monitor.
I just... You know what?
I just got a bit passionate.
You know, maybe I'm not so great judging the distance to the monitor, Ruffians.
It's not just the issue of smudges, you know?
I'm worried that she'll actually break the monitor with the force of her poke or just push it right off the desk.
You wouldn't like it too if that happened, right Ruffians?
Right.
Dead pixels can happen, that's not the problem!
It's everything!
So maybe... Maybe we can play Flash and Dreamer again if Lala learns to control her habit.
But... But how many times she's guilty of touching the monitor the other day?
I honestly don't know.
Sorry, Ruffians.
What about me?
I don't know.
This is something you decided, Moco-chan.
Stop touching the monitor.
Okay.
I can't.
I must.
I need to know exactly what dress I want to wear.
BAU BAU!
Is that the end of the sad news?
There was actually an incident.
An incident yesterday.
You know, maybe...
Some Ruffians didn't hear about the incident, but... Yesterday... Yesterday was the day that we started playing Metal Gear Solid for the very first time!
And because it's a special first, we wanted to play it as it was first released, and we bought a PS1 copy to play it as it was first, you know, first released!
Yeah, you know, it was great to go and everything!
Yeah, but...
We didn't realize that we kinda made a fatal error.
Do you know what it was?
Yeah.
That you can't save PS1 data onto a PS2 memory card.
Fuwawa made a mistake.
I asked.
She thought it was right.
But!
We thought that, you know, we might have had a solution and Papa Puppy was able to get us a used PS1 memory card really fast in no time at all!
But the PS2 wouldn't recognize it.
The game would recognize it, but the PS2 wouldn't.
So, the saga continues because Mama Puppy is now going to join in on the mission and help us acquire even more Memory Cards!
More Memory Cards!
Wish us luck, Ruffians, okay?
And, you know, if that doesn't work, we might be adding a PS1 to the console family.
BAU BAU!
We'll keep you updated, okay?
A PS1?
I've never had a PS1.
They're round, right?
That's kinda cool.
No, they're round.
The top is round, but it's not round itself.
Why not?
I want it to be round.
Can we ask them to make it round now?
Maybe the next one.
Maybe the PS6?
I was gonna say maybe the PS5.
I thought maybe it might be well needed for some Ruffians today, so... Good morning!
Good morning!
I don't see your eyelids open all the way there.
Are you awake yet?
Okay, well, it's okay this once, okay?
You can keep your eyelids closed if you want.
In case you can't tell with your eyes closed like that though, this is another Mococo Pup Talk, coming straight from me, Mococo!
You've been working hard, so it's okay to give yourself a little bit more time to rest in the morning, okay?
But, if you want to know a secret,
If you go to sleep even a little bit earlier than your usual sleep time, your body will thank you in the morning!
It's a secret though.
You know what will also thank you?
Me!
Mococo!
I'll thank you.
You can get even more time to sleep in the morning, you know, by adding just a bit more time on the other way.
But for now, don't worry.
You can rest just a bit more.
You've got a busy rest of the week ahead of you, so make sure not to be too harsh on yourself, okay?
You're doing your best.
And that's all you can do!
You know, even if no one else sees it, you know it's true.
And that's what's the most important.
I know you're doing awesome!
Be your own story's main character!
You're in control!
You can do it!
I believe in you!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the pup talk, Moco-chan.
You're welcome.
You're welcome!
Ruffians, do you feel a little bit more awake now?
It's okay.
This time it's okay.
Just this... Just this time, okay.
Yeah.
Well!
Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Ice!
It's ice!
Cute!
Is this the cutest Doggie of the Day?
Doggies of the day.
Look at what happens when you go on a walk, right Ruffians?
Good things happen!
You could... BAU BIG TIME!
Just like that!
Look at that!
The blue one is even a bit bigger too!
But we're the same height.
So cute!
But, you know... No laces can keep me contained, Ruffians, so... Yeah.
Even though they look similar, maybe... It's not us.
That's not us.
They're just dogs, okay?
Not Demon Guard Dogs.
Similis.
Different.
How did they BAU BAU?
If you know if they're anything like us, then... BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
Well, you know, just like the twin Demon Guard Dogs, FUWAMOCO, I think they're rather well-behaved.
They love to have fun and go for walks too.
You know, maybe they're even protecting the smiles of the lady who's taking them for a walk there.
Have fun on your walk now, FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians have been going on walks because we saw the FNOWFUWAMOCO debunked too, but what other walks have Ruffians been going on?
It was... De-den!
Mushrooms!
Science Experiment.
That's an awesome mushroom right there.
It looks like some inches right out of Mario, right?
I like the small one on the side too.
Very well, I.
Hydrated.
He's not as glamorous, but he's hydrated.
He's doing his best.
Actually, Ruffians, Moco-chan and I, we really like watching time-lapse videos of mushrooms growing.
We try growing mushrooms ourselves too, even.
That really healed me.
Ruffians, definitely don't eat any mushrooms you find on the walk, ever.
Unless you know!
But you should maybe ask a professional.
Even if you think you know, you don't know, so never... Yeah, ask a professional, okay?
Okay, never ever eat any mushrooms on the sidewalk.
Unless you're with a professional.
And that's not Moco-chan.
Got it.
BAU BAU!
I kinda wanna touch that one.
Don't touch them.
Don't touch.
Don't put them in your mouth.
Leave them be.
Just look.
Photo.
Yeah.
Ruffians, do you have any questions for us?
We do have a Question of the Day!
It is... De-den!
Hi ladies, I have a question.
I know you're both Demon Dogs, but upon careful inspection, it looks like you both have human ears as well as your dog's ears.
So I'm wondering which ears you use.
We have four ears.
It's kinda crazy.
But you know... Not really.
It's not really like that.
Because our human ears are just decoration.
They're just decoration.
You know, it's so that we don't scare humans and don't stand out even more than we already do.
All the hearing is done by our Demon Dog ears, okay?
And they do a pretty good job.
Right, but sometimes they do get a bit tired after playing games for a long time.
You know, especially since headphones aren't really made for a kind of fluffy and fuzzy ears too.
The majority of headphones.
My headphones are a bit different, but you know.
But, oh well.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions and for making FUWAMOCO Morning the kind of show it is all together with us.
Please remember we're always looking for more submissions, so...
Forget the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream... It's a bit different because this time we're taking off some time for our homework.
Yeah, we're gonna be taking some time to do homework so there won't be a stream tonight or tomorrow.
It's a bit scary.
Yeah, it's going to be...
Ruff for all of us, but we'll do our best to get as much homework as we can get done as fast as we can, Ruffians.
To be honest, it's a bit more difficult.
We'll be back on Friday for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
After that, we're going to be having a watch-along of our pick, our movie pick, Space Adventure Cobra.
So we hope you'll be there, Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a quick peek at the schedule once more.
Ah, yes.
We have... This weekend!
This weekend is Anime NYC!
At FUWAMOCO, we're going to be there together with Advent!
Our first convention appearance.
But, you know, Ruffians...
I think, you know, if you're a little bit further from New York City than you were before, then we'd like to suggest, very strongly suggest, that you make a VR chat!
Yeah!
It's free!
And you know, that way you can attend our Walk and War Mini, Walk and War Party Mini, and our Q&A time, virtually!
Exactly.
So, you know, even if you don't have paws on the ground in New York then, you can still attend!
This way you can still see us.
We hope that you'll be there, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
We'll still be here on Saturday and Sunday like always.
And we'll be reading Super Chats from this week!
We'll be the Super Chats for the Rock n' Rawr Party.
So don't wait!
BAU BAU!
We'll get to them, don't worry.
We're looking forward to it.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your support.
Thank you for waking us up.
Thank you for waking us up, Ruffians!
Thank you for waking us up!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
Adrien!
BAU BAU!
Doya Doya!
Mega Tricycle!
BAU BAU!
Z-Mix!
Four Scoops!
BAU BAU!
Snuff!
Ex-Alan!
BAU BAU!
Not Boy!
Tsundere Admiral!
BAU BAU!
Name Doko.
Doya Doya!
BAU BAU!
And to every Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!